hands up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 122 of game
programming so last time we basically
fixed up our button and I think we got
pretty much everything to work as far as
the standard button goes you can see
that if we press it it turns red and we
can release the mouse and action will be
performed and we can override pretty
much all the button behavior from
outside the button using all of our
different callbacks essentially and all
about different interfaces and classes
that we can put here so for example we
can provide the button with a we can set
a button listener which will let us
override all of these behaviors so
entered exited pressed and released
which is pretty awesome so that's the
deal with the button and has pretty much
complete now the thing that I promised I
would do last time is of course
basically give the button the ability to
set an image as as the actual button
right because in a game having text as a
button like that is usually not how
things go so for example in an
undermount guide as you know there is
like a little button for settings or a
little button for to return to the Nexus
and all that stuff it like it has a
little like icon essentially and you
press the icon and then that obviously
will perform something so um that being
said excuse me that being said we have
to actually implement that behavior
otherwise it's a little bit weird not
having that in our button class and we
will definitely need that going forward
which is why I'm doing this so that's
not open that button let's just go ahead
and open that button it's gonna be
pretty simple to create a button from a
an image okay all we're going to do is
we're going to give the the the bottom
class basically the ability to have any
kind of image okay doesn't have to be a
buffered image I'm pretty sure we might
run into some trouble hopefully we don't
throw I'm just gonna call it image I
look like a little icon image should be
fine to be honest and then when we
create this weekend we'll have a public
voice set image
how this is probably all out of water
and everything but let's just leave this
like this so if we set an image of
course for this it will go ahead and
just simply say this sort image equals
image and if we set null here then that
will basically be equivalent to just
clearing the image and then all we have
to do is draw the image okay so
basically what we say is if image
doesn't equal null then what we'll go
ahead and we'll do is essentially
everything got that so this will be else
oops okay so if image doesn't equal null
we'll go ahead and just draw the image
and you can see this is gonna be really
easy as well using Java graphical API
I've kind of gone ahead and not written
a pixel rasterizer kind of deal for the
for the UI as you know I'm kind of
because I'm rendering that it made a
resolution rather than upscaling by like
3 and also I've just decided that it's
probably a better idea and for you guys
as a bonus you I guess you guys get to
learn what what it's like kind of to use
two things well not necessarily that but
now you can say that you know how to do
everything from scratch yourself but
also you know how to use Javas api which
is also very important so we don't
actually need to specify width and
height I'm pretty sure here by the way
zero zero is clearly not what it's going
to be we'll go ahead and use this we'll
go ahead and just bring them out here so
that we don't have to calculate this
every time it shouldn't be too expensive
this stuff will usually be the instant
to calculate especially but this is just
this is just a I'm sure Java won't
create this on the heap or anything I
won't even enter memory so it's fine
anyway let's not get into the technical
aspects cuz this is Java and it's not
about that this is in C++ so that being
said we'll draw the image at X Y the
only reason I brought these out here is
just to meet the code cloner nothing to
do with performance okay cool brilliant
so there we go we've got it that's it
actually I'm not even kidding let's make
another constructor just for just for
this purpose um
I am going through we've got in this and
I believe that in this runs when isn't
it get cold I believe we were just to
run this we could look at the car at the
satirize so it runs when we call add
component right so when we add component
the component gets initialized so that
happens yet you can see that that
doesn't happen when we actually do the
button when we actually set when we
actually set up the button and create
the button so anyone goes out of the
panel so I'm not going to do that but I
am going to actually write a private
void in it okay and then this will
basically do pretty much all of this
stuff so all pretty much alter all the
kind of common stuff so we need to do
this stuff again and I'll call in it
from here we don't need to do any of
this because this stuff is just specific
to that essentially so label position
yeah that's fine you can see we passed
that along and then we've yeah we
probably didn't need to do that because
you can see there's really not much code
there but in case we had more is
probably a good idea to bring it out
into a method the reason I brought it
out into a method is because we're going
to use the same exact method in the
other constructor okay so we're going to
make another constructor which takes in
a position and a listener probably it
will take in a position an image and all
this enough oops okay we'll call Innes
definitely will position size will be
added here now for size I'm not sure
yeah we don't need that you can see we
can just pass position which is good
because the size is going to be the size
of the image by default only thing we
need to do any fancy scaling just make
your ass that's the right size and
you'll be fine now we don't need any of
that and really all we have to do is
make sure that we call set image then we
set the image okay I'm going to actually
call set image rather than this or the
image equals image just because if
you've got a cell you should call it
because this might do some fancy stuff
in the future
and we don't want to kind of you know
have to to two paths to reach the same
destination that's always a bad thing so
there we go that should be pretty good
excuse me
that's yeah I mean that's pretty much it
I'm pretty sure so if we go back into
play let me just bring up the resources
and the let's just see if we've got a
nice text show we can just display as an
icon so it's not really you have
anything do we I guess we could like
display play a front or something in
fact let's do something like that
so res textures and play a front so the
way that we'll provide an image it is
will create a button here your Y button
I will call this image button equals new
UI button the back that what the
position will make is probably going to
be a new vector2 I'm just looking up
here we'll make it something like maybe
10 and then like 360 or something new
image will be we can actually just do
something like image ioad read new file
res textures and play it front dot PNG
and then action listener will just be we
could probably just put no I want to put
in all that will make it just do the
same thing as this I'll just copy and
paste this okay there we go so that is
the deal okay let's come up here quickly
import the file of course that's the try
cash let's surround this whole thing
with try-catch and then we'll just do
something like I'm actually going to
extend this API to just taken a path to
be honest because this is madness but um
will do something like panel dots add
component in each one all right let's
see what happens a crash so null pointer
exception what's wrong so it looks like
label was now okay that's fine
so what try to in needs that we had
about it out of that and then okay I see
so we don't want to do this we only want
to do this
so if label doesn't even know we had
that if it's not we don't want to do
anything with that and now we've got a
nullpointerexception again wow this is
going great
what is null here size is now okay
that's a problem so update okay
we do need a size the reason we need a
size is because we want we need to be
able to yeah we absolutely needed size
the reason the size is important is
because we want to be able to check the
logic of whether or not the button is
being pressed and of course to figure
out if the mouse is on top of the button
we use unit size so instead of passing
in nothing I'm going to pass in new
vector2 i imaged on yeah width that's
weird image dot we might have a special
profit image if this is really this bad
and I get high it looks like it is as
bad okay Buffett image it is a Buffett
images pretty much the implementation we
want to use anyway so I'm not sure
anyone if anyone would use anything else
other than this
so ah this will return a boffin him into
anyway so there we go now it's pretty
good
let's run this success so you can see
the the guy is down here and if we click
him how we get a boolean our pointer
yeah didn't even have to there's not
much that can go wrong in this line of
code except from actionlistener
being null why is that not that
shouldn't be no oh yeah we forgot this
whoops let's make sure we do that Hey
all right click and you can see
actionperformed works as if it was any
other button now let's quickly make a
button because I'm feeling adventurous
today we'll go ahead and we'll make it
so we'll make it 16 by 16 and we'll make
like a kind of Nexus thing now you guys
know my control so don't be too harsh
here I want to filter things pink first
when I select my pencil I'm going to
kind of selected a dark kind of great
here and I want to try and draw that
next I think it was like from memory
because I haven't actually played realm
of the mad God since 2012 I think the
next is not that we have to copy them or
anything but I think it was something
like this oh look at that I was just
perfect
look at me maybe I can draw maybe I
should be in hottest little jerks okay
so there we go
ah that looks pretty good I don't know
if I need to add things to it I'm pretty
happy with that
I wasn't even in the center well that's
that's okay can't be in the center it
can be we could be really cool and do
something like this okay that's going to
be the deal for now I don't really care
obviously so go ahead and we'll save
that into whoops into this directory so
we'll call this for now we'll just call
this home so debates in textures right
now but you know whatever we'll go ahead
and set the image here to be hot pantry
there you go it's rendering with ounce
that alpha thing and it's also very
small so maybe we shouldn't have made it
quite that small 16 by 16 is tiny let's
go ahead and fix the Alpha not render
anything because of course we're not
rendering it ourselves so
look I'm gonna be honest the easiest way
to do this it's just I'm not sure I'm
not sure I don't know Java's API well
enough to say whether or not it's got
like I said alpha color type deal it
probably does I mean maybe he does
actually I'm not sure oh let's quickly
just explore that image - I've set image
darts and you do alpha maybe doesn't
okay so the easiest way to do this is
just going to be to make your UI
elements actually have alpha so we can
do that by selecting everything that's
pink
so we'll just there it is okay and then
just deleting it okay so that way it's
gonna save it as a 32-bit image file
which calls Java can handle and it
should be better it should be the best
so there you go now let's I forgot that
this was a dark grey so let's maybe
select first of all let's just buff this
up a little bit and also let's select a
better color maybe so we'll just
basically drag that like that and maybe
that will work better I'm not sure I'm
not really in the business of making
this look at Daleks like absolute
rubbish let's scale it up see this is
one of those videos that is
unfortunately turning out to be more of
a I was horrible turning out to be more
of a UH art lesson and not a very good
one either nearest-neighbor please
alright that's pretty good because if we
resize the image or whatever just
recently so there you go we've got a bit
of a button here so let's make that
button to quit the game because one our
systems or exits there
boom done no that's you know something
you probably should use in your code
system at Isis since it'll just
basically crash the game without doing
anything like for example saving but
anyway that looks pretty good to me so
we've got basically every kind of button
I'm pretty sure we've got I'm pretty
sure we've got the ability to create and
here we want remember if you do want to
change this on click or something on on
mouse-over yeah what you could do
I'm not excuse me I'm not actually going
to bother with implementing that myself
what I'll do instead you know you guys
do that because as in I'm not going to
put into the API I don't think it's
necessary well you can do is you can
simply override the UI button listener
and then just set on on entered you can
be like changed the image to something
else for example and you can make make
it like a lighter version of the image
or if you were cool you could even edit
the pixel so that you don't have to have
two images you could do whatever you
want right it's up to you you can always
create a buffer damage from a bunch of
pixels so you could you know read this
image and then change the color
in fact just because I know that I'm
going to get questions being like what
did what did he mean let's go ahead and
I'll give you guys an example of this
and we'll call it a day or call it a
night
so this is the image
that we that we read I was going to also
extend me I go a little bit but let's
crew that so we'll have image and we'll
have image halva or something alright so
not sure why it is just caught it's just
caused so much trouble what's wrong with
this is an image okay so what we'll do
is we'll get the Rasta gets data buffer
get data you know we'll do the same
thing we did what is this without a
buffer and or something we'll do the
same thing we did at the beginning of
the entire series they're gonna work no
it's not because I'm missing in brackets
best maybe not best okay now it's good
yay
okay um we'll set that to know what's up
in bits now this is a definite same
thing that we did at the beginning at
the beginning we did the same thing okay
what that does is it gives us a
reference to the pixels inside this
inside this image okay so this is a
reference okay it's not a copy so if we
change these pixels it's going to change
the pixels of snide image okay one of
the biggest things that I saw that
people didn't understand when I look
back three years because it's been that
long well when I look back three years
and I look at the first episode and I
look and I look at the comments the
number one thing I see is people are
like well how on earth to do the pixels
in image get updated well the deal is
this isn't like another variable we're
making that gets set equal to this it's
a reference okay because arrays arrays
in Java by default in fact arrays and
objects in Java by default just get
basically passed by reference all the
time you can't control that and then
every primitive value like a boolean or
an integer gets passed my value that
being said since we've got a reference
to it if we change these pixels
it's going to actually change the pixels
in the image which means that the image
will be modified okay it's pretty cool
because it's it's a really easy way to
do that we could have done something
weird like imaged I'll set RGB and you
can see that you can set individual
pixels that stuff is very slow and
excuse me not very nice and code anyway
so let's say we have this so what we can
do now is basically say that I'm going
to create another version of this image
image called image hover you can see if
we try to make a new profit image there
is definitely a way to make this from a
pixel array I have no idea what it is
I've never done this before so let me
just Google that buffered image from
pixel array okay stackoverflow oh my god
it's terrible
oh no it's not I thought it was but it's
not because I said hey the guy on
stackoverflow used set RGB for
everything but instead I just realized
we can create a new image to take the
reference of that and then set them
equal to this so best but um basically
what we'll do is we will we'll do this
we'll say image so we're creating
another image was the same width height
as the other one again this will be type
int a RGB makes you use a RGB not RGB
because we want transparency we an alpha
Channel what we're going to do is we're
going to go through every pixel in the
original pixel so we'll say image get
height Y force losses topped this
tutorial has really blossomed into more
than just what you guys bargained for a
bit is why an axe already in use yes it
is I want to be cool so I call this just
why why because I don't want to I'm
terrible with variable names
okay so there you go you got you got
everything here now basically now what
we're going to do is we're going to
basically do the same thing as this so
we'll call this original pixels and then
we'll call this new pixels and then
that's going to just get it from image
hover okay and then all we have to do is
set new pixels so if we were to set new
pixels X X plus y times image we can use
you can see I'm using just the other
images width and height they're the same
right we created the new image with the
same width as the original image so do
it the same equals original pixels now
if we just did that yeah it would just
copy the image that's cool but what we
want to do is we want to actually
extract the color so let's say something
like in two color equals that okay and
we can do something like let's just say
we want to brighten it by this yeah we
could do this
yeah I'm showing you guys are really
good there's an easier way to do this
for this case because you can see
everything is just one color but I'm
showing you guys just a general case of
how we can do this in retrospect I
probably should start but anyway into
another video but anyway that aside
we'll extract we don't really care about
the Alpha channel so we'll just extract
the RGB channels so we'll do something
like color and so the red Channel is
that one and we'll extract that I'm not
going to go over how this works it's
really simple
and if you guys want me to cover this
kind of stuff in more detail you can
although people always drop a comment um
let's just get rid of these extra things
ain't don't need that's okay what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say R plus
equals now I don't know how much again
I'm you should clamp this to be no
greater than 255 but we're at like 142
right now you can see RGB so we probably
will
let's just say we'll go up like 50 or
something that should be safe all right
and then now we can be like this equals
color so the Alpha Channel
so we'll do something like color and
that that'll be shifted 24 okay now we
do the real stuff so we have the red
Channel
so we are reconstructing the color now
okay we've got the red channel there in
channel on the blue Channel so I will
probably divide these up like that just
that it looks but just hey guys can say
it be
oh whoops there any of that sorry my bad
this should have been shifted right
let's see we're doing yep I got
distracted by talking to you guys all
right there we go
no need for that that'll bring
everything back we did need to do it for
this though that's why I got distracted
there we go so we've brightened
everything up by 50 now the reason I did
this was because it doesn't matter what
color it is now yeah I don't prove it
I'll have like a little section of green
which I'll just cleverly check to make
sure it's below the threshold and I'll
probably just make this section here
green okay we'll see if it works for
that but let's not should be good so now
what we can do is we can be like image
button set button listener new UI button
listener and what will do is will
override just one method public void l22
methods so let's go back to the UI
button listener this is taking one of my
thoughts bus
it proves that this API is pretty solid
I think since you can do all this so
instead of buttoned I'll set color will
say buttons I'll set image for both of
them so when we enter we'll set it equal
to image hopper and when we exist I
really hope this works by the way
because I've never done this before
we'll set it equal to this yeah I'm not
sure if we think you're please mark this
final it will work right but then we
might not be able to do this stuff okay
so new plan
puffin image image image fall fall and
we just get rid of where is it
we'll get rid of last oops mass okay
cool
there you go so exited we set a
difficult to that entered and then
exited we said back to this so let's see
what happens a crash a class cast
exception okay
it was that not right let's see what we
had in game no that uh that does look
right what happened where am I did I
what
why is it a class cast exception that's
a dot above the dog and I'm sure we can
cast that that's it failed loading or
something that's a bit weird
no come on you have time for your
stupidity Java
look what's image did it load the image
it should it right I even know what the
frickin width is
with 32 well yeah it looks like a load
of the image but then it lasts cause
ejection why that should be totally
legit see that same code that was um
yeah let me just copy this
I'm sure it's identical but maybe
there's an extra bracket something I
didn't mention no there's not
Oh worst worst Java why is this
happening why are you hacking me I
really don't know what the deal is guys
it looks like it should be working this
returns a buffered image we used a
buffered image here how is this code any
different maybe it's because it's from
the image uh I don't know does it work
from see if it works with it for this
little thing this is annoying I was
hoping this would just work but you can
see that it's being really annoying I'm
just kinda taking a whack here making it
compile it works for this one what maybe
we can't write to it because it got
loaded from a thing what that is just
bizarre and that doesn't make any sense
it shouldn't affect that right why does
it happen to that lime not this one the
only difference is this image was loaded
in its may it marked it as I don't know
maybe it screwed it up somehow that's
really annoying though because that
means that we'll have to rate it
ourselves potentially Oh okay if anyone
fees us out let me know I don't have
time with this so I'm just going to
write a for loop
well why don't wanna is Curtis and Gary
mirrors plus plus close that's great
so it looks like looks like we can get
rid of original pixels then we can just
write and write the array at the same
time okay
new pixels X X X plus y times image like
get with equals image don't get RGB xxx
yyy cat is that how does that get the
image let me just quickly inspect this
okay object in doubt okay
I went too far also don't get other
elements that's weak
that's weak all right
yeah done so we'll say color equals that
then will reconstruct its that should
work are you okay null pointer that's
better why is that no well because you
know no no it can't be
I can be hang on well I'm lost now this
should be up here this should work I
think yeah we'll see what happens well
maybe not all right I'm kind of sorry
that I decided to do this
that's zeros I'm kind of sorry that I
decided to do this now
it looks like this game programming
episode just took a turn okay that
worked my maths must be wrong it's
usually never that so that's definitely
correct new pixels image like it unless
it's just not reading that properly I
bet it's just something to do with that
man okay show me what the pixels are and
they're fine that's white so no that's
fine to know about white maybe that's
transparent I don't know oh yeah that
would have been mmm well the alpha zero
so it's fine but um yeah that's fine
that's legit so what's going on why you
ahead up we get the channels we
definitely did stuff to them we set new
pixels back
what are these getting set to it looks
like they're getting set to looks like
they just don't have an alpha Channel
okay that's definitely not nothing
hmm let's try setting the alpha 2 white
2 full or what what's going on this
doesn't make any sense
okay there we go so you can see it you
can see it brightens it up but why on
earth did the Alpha Channel hate me for
oh I know why it's because I'm an
absolute [ __ ] sometimes that's what I
meant to do or not we didn't need to
shift it Oh what we did if it's like
that
what is that men okay yeah I know what
the problem is I know the problem is
it's because if we do one really like
this we have to we have to properly
reduce it to be a bite because it's not
a bite right now it's like four bites so
we need to basically do this even though
we're not really going to use it or
alternatively alternatively we could do
this we could do this and then just do
that and then that should work yay so
you can see how it makes the image
brighter now I'm so sorry that that took
so long I don't know why the biggest
problem was the fact that you can't
apparently get get the buffer from a
buffered image that you load in from a
file for some reason if anyone knows why
that was exploiting on me please let me
know but there you go you can see that
um we have a button that now changes it
becomes brighter right except it works
with the green or whatever well we were
probably just on this up even further
there you go you can really see it now
and in fact just so you guys look at
that see it's getting brighter when I
put my mouse over it pretty cool so you
guys don't a complain that I didn't show
you close enough anyway thanks for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode now if you did enjoy the episode
and you want the source code and other
rewards then be sure to support me on
patreon so patreon is a pretty cool
website where you basically pledge
something and it's usually either per
month or per video I've my patreon sperm
which means that you can basically
pledge any amount of money per month to
me and you get some pretty sick rewards
for this so if you pledge five dollars
or more you get access to the entire
source code of the game programming
series through a github repository okay
so basically what happens is when you
pledge $5 or more please the other thing
is the other important thing is that
since since it's a monthly contribution
into pledge and patron collects these
pledges at the beginning of the month if
you guys pledge like for example on the
10th of like August then you will get it
at the beginning of September right you
won't get it straight away but however
it happens to be like the 28th of
September right now so if you guys
pledge right now you will get it in like
a few days rather than having to wait a
month so it's a really good time to get
onto this pledging game it helps me make
a lot more videos and high-quality
videos as well and of course it also
gives you guys access to some pretty
cool things and of course the $10 more
you do get access to a pretty cool email
address where I will basically just
reply to you and help you out with any
any programming related topics or any
life topics to be honest that are in my
power to help out with and why not and
you basically get some pretty cool
support from me but basically you know
that that's for the super users but for
the just for the general public I feel
like the $5 per month is a really good
deal and and yeah especially cuz it's
the end of the month so we'll get a new
batch of people in the github repository
now so thanks for watching guys if you
did enjoy please be sure to hit a like
button and I'll see you guys very soon
with another with another episode of
game programming goodbye
you